last year congressional Republicans
you'll remember passed a major tax
reform bill it accomplished a big goal
for them and for many of their donors
but tax reform wasn't what Republicans
ran on in 2016 popular as it may be now
at the time they ran you'll remember on
immigration and a promise to treat
America's borders like they are actual
borders and matter like this was a real
country now some Republicans in Congress
want to betray that pledge in the most
dramatic possible way they're working
tonight to pass a so-called discharge
petition in the house it would force
votes on a slew of immigration measures
including some that would give amnesty
to millions of illegal immigrants how
many well we can't say because when you
push on the numbers a little bit it
turns out that nobody actually knows how
many illegal immigrants live in this
country and when we say nobody knows we
mean nobody knows to within like ten
million the estimate you hear from
almost everyone is 11 million 11 million
illegal aliens living in this country
that number comes from Pew
it hasn't changed in a decade and that
should be a tip-off because over the
last decade illegal arrivals have
continued and now states are actively
sabotaging deportation efforts the real
figure it turns out is much much higher
ice director Thomas Holman admitted that
much last year so we know 11 million is
not correct so what's the real number
well an unpublished paper by Yale three
professors their estimates there could
be twenty three million illegal
immigrants in the United States they're
low-end estimate is seventeen million
even back in two thousand five analysts
at Bear Stearns guessed the real number
was probably twenty million illegal in
this country or more the bottom line is
we don't know exactly how many are here
but some members of the House Republican
caucus think it is a good idea to give
amnesty to some of them or maybe all of
them now some of their voter voters
wanted of course but they apparently
don't care congressman Jeff Denham is a
Republican representing California he
joins us tonight congressman thanks for
coming up Tucker thanks for having me
back again shouldn't we figure out how
many illegal immigrants are in this
country before we encourage more to come
what we should do is actually secure our
border and the only way we're gonna give
the border security is actually working
together to pass something off the floor
the president continues to talk about
twenty five billion and a secure border
making sure these caravans aren't coming
across stop this to give the catch and
release program this is the only way we
actually bring up that debate and
actually put something on the
President's desk but wait a second
giving amnesty to people encourages more
people to come here illegally we know
that it was tried in 1986 and that was
its effect its its effect every single
time so before we get more people coming
across and border security nobody takes
seriously because it's always been a
joke why shouldn't we know how many are
here and why isn't Congress determined
to find out how many are here it seems
like kind of a baseline issue yeah
Tucker rather than just doing a census
to figure out how many people are here
why don't we stop them from coming here
in the first place doing nothing means
another 500,000 people will cross our
border every single year I've been in
the majority now for eight years that's
four million people shouldn't we stop
right now and actually do what the
president's asking us for even something
that the Democrats had proposed a few
years ago and actually provides the
funding building the border security do
the surveillance make sure that we
actually have a guarantee to the
American public that we've stopped this
influx across our southern border okay
well how about this why don't you
support punishing any employer caught
employing an illegal alien a illegal
alien really punishing them checking
every employer in America would verify
universal and making sure that nobody's
employing illegal aliens in lieu of
American workers why not do that
starting I don't know tomorrow well as
you know any government program
especially a new government program that
needs technology doesn't start tomorrow
I do support you verify I do support a
comprehensive University verify yeah
absolutely but we have to we have to fix
the rest of our immigration process
first
right now we have said Republicans have
said for quite some time now we will now
pass a comprehensive bill but yet that's
what's being proposed today I want us to
support what the president has talked
about dealing with border security
dealing with our dreamers right now
because they're in a different situation
after following their government and
signing up for
we need to resolve that they following
our government we encourage them to come
here illegally with their parents no we
had a present of the past an executive
order which I disagreed with but
nevertheless the President of the United
States have passed an executive order
that allowed daca recipients to step
forward so these kids who have graduated
from our high schools who've grown up in
this country who know of no other
country or no other home they've done
what the countries asked him to do and
they've signed up for this executive
order it's like their country they're
not citizens ok ok ok which is back up
right but I'm just saying in a world
where there are a lot of priorities why
is this your number one priority in your
state you've got more than a hundred
thousand people living on the sidewalk
those are American citizens why don't
you deal with the problem like that
first or securely versus first before
you start passing out citizenship to
people who here illegally I don't
understand yeah that's kind of a an
argument that I get some from some of
the liberal networks why would you have
a priority or this priority I believe on
addressing a number of different issues
at the same time what are you doing
about the hundred thousands living
outside tonight ok but it's a look
giving citizenship and voting rights to
people who are here illegally is not a
way of securing our border so why
wouldn't you care the border because we
heard your student president has asked
for including his four pillars but the
main thing that he continues to talk
about the president asked for a solution
on daca and for border security I
believe that we can give him both ok but
why I mean let's leave the president out
of this just as someone who is hired to
represent American citizens speaks
slowly so I can understand why would we
give citizenship to anybody here
illegally give voting rights to anyone
who's whose family stuck and who came
here illegally before not a single new
person crosses that border illegally
until you can work your voters in the
face and say our borders secure now
maybe we can give citizenship to
illegals sure and that dynamic changed
under the previous president but first
of all I don't believe in giving anybody
anything
this would be an earned
pathway by all of the different bills it
would be at least a 10 to 12 year
process so though you'd first sign up
for five years of a temporary green card
that would allow you to work or go to
school or sign up for the military and
at the end of five years after you've
passed a background check you paid your
fine in your fee
you've actually proven that you're not
on government subsidies and you're out
there working or going to school or
serving your country at the end of five
years that's your reward the meal that
you're talking about that is that will
happen is another five years doing it
all over again so it's a twelve year
process ten years before you'd actually
be able to get a legal permit everybody
else does it why not okay but why not
just look millions of people want to
come here why would you give a path to
citizenship for people here legally
ahead of people who are waiting in line
obeying our laws I don't understand I
may be used I guess and it's a 12-year
process and I believe that this Earned
pathway this earned 12-year process
would put you at the back of the line
but certainly somebody who's been who
who's graduated from our schools that's
been in our community that has followed
the executive under order under Obama
should have that opportunity and look
looked in the lead wait to see what
happens okay you know what as a
congressman representing California you
got a lot of problems I mean a lot of
problem you have a number of uh yeah you
do and so like why would this be
anywhere near the top of your party list
I'm just completely confused these are
not American citizens you've got tens of
millions of hurting American citizens in
your state and you're putting these
people ahead of them and I don't
understand it well you're elected to
lead and we've got to do something and
the president campaigned on border
security the only way we're going to get
that because you know the the rules of
this house and and the Senate you've got
to get 60 votes the only way you're
going to get the sixty members on a
bipartisan border security bill is with
this solution that is equally as
important that the President of the
United States is asking for congressman
thank you very much I appreciate it